address okay situations too broad oh
because decision support systems
generally excel in marrow situations
where the specification is plus program
so this is about the situation that this
is about what you how you respond okay
all right another answer hmm isn't that
this like humans make decisions on the
spot relatively confident because
computers calculators I disagree I
disagree i think the decision will come
faster on a computer if it's if you're
talking our country numbers a computer
will do way faster than any human could
like it feels calculating risk and stop
arguing with me encounter that is all
often calculated it would do it
numerically i disagree i still going to
go if you are you on speed the decision
support system will be in the computer
will win based on smith and i'll give
you a classic example i'll give you a
classic example when you're talking
about balancing out risks in that kind
of thing okay the big sort of um a big
and you guys should the snap is so you
don't overlap okay a big one shed moment
for decision support systems was when
garry kasparov who knows who garry
kasparov was is a chess master right and
i think she can remember as like he lost
to a computer design by IBM right and
what it came down to it because chess is
very much about balancing up choices
making a risky decision all I kind of
think the computer bit of hands down
okay why what specific place more
specific please thank you computers can
analyze risks to right so this idea that
only humans can do that is not sure now
we can program computers to do the same
and they can do much faster than we can
it can process millions of say in the
exam
chess moves and board scenarios before
we've even done like a few dozen ok so
if you can get for speed if your are you
miss feed I'm not going to pay I'll give
you one more try no caves please humans
make a decision that is like take
everything into account then they slowly
eliminate each thing one black one right
like like they compared that I really do
that well we're comparing more than two
or three things at once a few possess
him of 10 items they'll make me do like
ABC done they like a and C an Okie be
and then fell out of d and half the Mac
in half and then out of that dog came
eliminating today come to one where's
Kofi REO straight for just analyze
everything because it doesn't have like
remembering disability isn't that a
strength of the decision support system
not a weakish okay right I think that
one two three four five six seven eight
one two three four five six and so that
would be half six and a half now I'm I'm
calling team doctor riddance I
I have every finish makes the decision
to quit cuz come back wait I thought you
say they weren't quick enough before now
they're too quick I'm sorry sorry guys
get out the call of duty it's time and
guys it's the bird has sailor with you
sorry okay well gotta run okay oh that's
not too bad okay to all of your credit I
think we had a lot of good reasons for
Bernstein's ok so you can Hopi windows
all right